self-driving vans will carry passengers
for the first time this morning in a
Texas City the app-based service starts
a six-month pilot project in Frisco
north of Dallas drive AI is the first
company to launch a self-driving test
with passengers since an uber SUV an
autonomous driving autonomous driving
mode killed a pedestrian in Arizona this
year only on CBS this morning
Kris Van Cleave got early access to the
program and filed this report good
morning this sign won't say human driver
for long because today this car is going
fully autonomous and it's going to be
taking passengers now this comes at a
time when there are still some questions
about safety and self-driving cars I'm
super excited I'm really intrigued to
see how this goes to because it's kind
of wild Ryan Thompson was among the
first to sign up to use the new
autonomous vehicle service drive ai
launches today in Frisco Texas his first
ride started by pushing that green
button you anxious at all a little okay
this is something that you hear about
them on the news or online or whatever
but you don't really get a chance to
actually experience yourself the vans
will operate an autonomous mode on a
nearly 2 mile route with a safety driver
on board going between a giant office
park with 10,000 workers and a nearby
dining and entertainment complex over
the next six months the company plans to
add more destinations and phase out that
safety driver what we're trying to do is
provide transportation solutions for
people between work play and stay it's
sort of last mile issue right drive AI
joins way mo owned by Google's parent
company in running self-driving vehicles
with passengers uber stopped its
passenger tests after its crash in March
killed a pedestrian so you feel like
that type of accidents an avoidable
accident it is something that we have
absolutely designed around and then we
are taking every precaution that we can
to make sure that type of incident
doesn't happen the vans have radar on
the grille
infrared light our sensors and 10
cameras on the roof to give them a
360-degree view of the road
they also feature screens on their sides
front and rear alerting pedestrians and
drivers to what the driverless car is
doing inside this screen shows
passengers what the car seats do you
any safety concerns with this launching
we feel very confident and its ability
to be safe in our community and safer
than the human driver would be frisco
mayor jeff cheney i feel strongly that
this is very much a test and to get
public acceptance but when we come back
and look at frisco five years from now
and certainly ten years from now it will
be all over our roads testing
self-driving cars on public roads
remains controversial as federal
regulations are stalled on capitol hill
and recent polls show nearly seventy
percent of americans are uncomfortable
with sharing the road with an autonomous
vehicle only twenty one percent say
they'd be likely to ride in one they
should be using proving grounds right
now it's simply too dangerous
Automotive News Editor in Chief Keith
Crain proofing grounds are the place to
test unproven technology there's a lot
of great stuff in the autonomous vehicle
but we don't know if they work yet it's
trippy to be in the car that's driving
itself
it's very trippy Ryan Thompson went from
skeptic to superfan in about two miles I
would hop in this without a driver and
are beat I'm that confident and we've
been doing this for a couple minutes if
all goes well with the pilot the plan is
to expand the service to more Frisco and
make it permanent here for CBS this
morning Kris Van Cleave Frisco Texas
it's the future it's here these stories
are gonna in the five to ten years these
stories are all gonna look so clean
antiquated rather than antiquated the
self-driving cars that don't want to be
on the road with human pilots right
right